what do you want gringo what are you
doing here
have you heard there's a war going on my
name is John Marston been sent here to
retrieve a couple of men can I speak to
your commander you want to talk to my
boss gringo I guess because I'm now good
enough for you
no sir you think you're better than me
you come to my country my poor little
country and you think you can be friends
with the president
no sir so I'm sorry sir things must have
come out wrong maybe you can help me
[Laughter]
sure somewhere between a threatening
stare and the soldiers armed to the
teeth
yeah and then we'll talk my name is
Capitan be centered a Santa John Marston
my country is being John Master terrible
pain
the rebels has ceased the people by the
throat and destroy our way of life no
politician sir and I am no soldier akela
but we were both beholding to our time a
brave man perhaps you've heard of him
Coronel and London he's trying to
preserve the order in our province to
keep our civilization and life stuff
the people are confused usually Swede
sometimes in the service of what is
right it breaks my heart I also know
moralist sir I wish I enjoy your films
mr. monster I'm trying to find a man an
American an outlaw named Bill Williamson
I believe he came here to seek
protection from another outlaw named
Javier escuela you're no modernist but
you hunt at loss so same you heard
anything of these men i undergoing or
what is left
I lost seek each other there are
possibly hiding with thieves and killers
who pose as freedom fighters and the
hills around here
they're united under one trader named
over time yes
where could I find this race if I knew I
would be there hunting him with
everything that is true within me they
just find you like cholera something
like that but it's possible though my
men are trying to lull him into a trap
possibly you could write with us and if
everything goes okay I'm sure the
Coronel will help you okay
- you can take your horse right on the
wagon
follow me we're headed to tuberosa
you
such a warm welcome from the Mexican
army I can see I didn't know what to
expect
I haven't even cross the border now it's
being shot at you will hear a lot of
words like violence and oppression here
words other peasants have been done but
do not understand meaningless words
there be suffering that Isis a
reputation leaving I've heard about the
colonel down here he's not famous for
his compassion this is the point how do
you make a lawyer do you know he just
would be nice to her baby I enter this a
good man a strong man he carries the
wing of a million problems on his
shoulders am I supposed to midium your
wrinkles are so quick to touch badly of
other people because I've made you feel
better about yourselves maybe you should
you're the one talking about this and I
ain't here to make judgement on the way
of your government I've got enough
problems with my own right now it's
season America's in your mouth
we are for darkness mistake a different
form what is better
kundo our Madonna hungry man north of
beef so he grows
the wheat I think you need to answer
that question yourself
who are these articles you want this
Billy the cowboy and his Mexican friend
to waves it's a fella I used to know and
Javier escuela y knew him too
what do you mean you know this man we
was friends once part of the past I
can't seem to get rid of the bus it's
all that's real my friend and cannot be
in place that is the problem with the
people here they spent too much time
dreaming about imaginary futures I know
I can't change the past
I'm sure gonna do something about the
future whatever helps you sleep at night
amigo my country is full of American
criminals mostly in the service of the
rebel beats Mexico is an easy place were
made to lose himself whether he wants to
get lost or not hopefully not too easy
they got much time to find these man it
must be a hype but I saw no hit the
highest price and I asked how much I'm
not getting paid it's it's a long story
being made to do this I will never
understand you Americans we did we have
a system or throw at me they can run
with their own if you help us we help
you no one Heights really in me
it is how he sees it is killing this
pumpkin don't people have the right to
stand up for themselves the right the
right
don't you throw silly ideas at me what
do you know about the rights of American
people very little just saying there
must be something behind this rebellion
Oh though you was behind the single
muscle nice insidious lie the best are
scooped in that cows they can be hurting
it only takes a few minutes remove many
maybe they've just had enough to be
called stupid we're talking about things
you don't understand you asked me
something I'm gonna give you an answer
are you on a revolutionary it's not what
you here was once I suppose and a
twisted kind of way thought I could
change something if I thought hard about
change
what I don't know maybe that was the
problem solutions and he's nothing but
clean and evil individuals putting their
own need to put those of others it is
people fighting for change where they
have no idea what change is you're a
poor man who's been beat down all of
I've any change it's gonna seem good
what you
the government it's going to make a poor
man sweets
you're not helping them it's only
natural they're gonna look for someone
else it will tie a cherry berry night
what do you want us to walk around
giving our money every port fashion and
make what a terrible idea
first they need to look at why they're
poor then they need to go out and do
some work rather than sitting on the
couch talking about freedom
who's this man we're looking for leader
of the rebels but I'm Reyes
he's a great I like power in the Senate
a hero who has done nothing for no
respects [ __ ] I looked this morning
I ever worked with a pathetic warm
that's a nice image
he is from a rich family I meant morning
I called the credit who possess the
fight for the food is taking advantage
of the ignorant and the weak mind
you must be telling the people so from
their water here of course is all that
bastard does is telling about go give it
speech it is easy to make promises you
can never beat it takes more than a few
promises to build an army please what
Wow
nothing else he doesn't care about
anybody but itself is prepared to
destroy everything my pacifism both in
Thai food just people shout his name
for now are you ready ready for what we
will lure the rebels into a trap
there's a train leaving to burrow so
soon we're going to squirt and we'll
think it's a surprise right
I have no supplies sunny very clever we
must throw it in some bait they can
reduce
the thing is with what are you waiting
for
hunt your heart Domino's
let's go
[Music]
oh yeah Barrett they're a good team for
meheeco today
well I am they will be very pleased
this is standard drain district is a
regular store pagando Marcin you're
gonna have to do something what you have
to go out there and start the train
before it crosses the bridge